>> So thank you for
inviting me today,
I'm really excited to be here.
The title of my presentation
probably you should say
that I'm from an
Information Science School.
I'm a PhD candidate,
I'm graduating in June.
Okay. So the title of
my presentation is
the Making of Fungible
Open Data in Biomedicine,
and most of my presentation will
be dedicated to explain you
the socio-technical but also
epistemic societal
challenges involved
in reusing genomic data
in Biomedicine,
Research Genomic Data.
But before going into that,
I also want to give
you an overview,
a short overview of
my research values
and interests of my domain,
influences and
methods that informed
my research during my
years as a PhD student and
then short overview of
my collaborative projects because
I've done quite a lot
in collaboration with
other departments so I want to
point out these projects and
then we'll give you a lot of
details probably more than
what you want to hear about
my dissertation project.
Since this is a job talk,
I figured that I wanted you to
know who I am as a researcher,
what I care about
and why I want to
be a researcher in
the first place because
with all the things
that I could do
right now especially working
with data and people,
why do I want to be
a researcher, right?
My main interest is
really in epistemology.
Since I have memories,
I have been really interested
in understanding how
people make sense of
the word in different ways,
what kind of means they use
to make sense of the word,
and why do we have all these
different perspectives,
and how we end up with
different perspectives.
So this is what I always
been interested into and
that's also why I probably have
a master degree in journalism,
so it's curiosity driven.
But then over
the last seven years,
I really became interested in
data epistemologies more
specifically and
code epistemologies,
and everything started
seven years ago
when I was working as
a journalist and also I was
finishing my master
in media studies.
And during that time,
I witnessed the widespread
sudden diffusion
of data and adoption of
data-driven techniques
by Italian journalists.
It was a new thing back then,
and this was because the Italian
government back then,
it was inspired by the
Obama's Open Data Initiative,
started to release all these
statistics and data and
demographic and
transportation data
about Italian citizens.
So as journalists we were very
enthusiastic of how these
[inaudible] was back in
my master thesis which
was supposed to be on
these topics of how to use
the statistics for storytelling.
And myself I wrote some
articles using APIs from
Twitter and Facebook and
talking about how then,
already how the network
back then was
talking about specific and
understanding social issues,
but then at some point I stopped.
And I stopped because I realized
that we really had no
idea what we were doing.
So as journalists, we had
no training in social
science research methods.
We had no conception of issues
of validity, reliability,
generalizations,
bias in the data,
we didn't know anything
about these things,
and I saw that some of us
we were using
statistics to become
big claims that were not always
back with good datasets.
And then especially I was
particularly bothered
while by one event.
So the Italian government
was trying to pass
this law on sexual harassment,
on the phenomenon of
sexual harassment in Italy,
and some of the
journalists they use
some public statistics to
undermine these phenomenon
and showing that it wasn't
such a big thing as the people
were pushing for this law
to pass while saying
that it was them.
So at that point I decided to,
instead of writing
my dissertation about how
to use statistics
for storytelling,
more about the limits
and how the statistics.
So I became more interested
in writing about statistics
then using the type of
this data analysis myself
for my own storytelling.
If that makes sense
to you guys I think.
Okay, and that's
also when I realized
that there's none of which
served in 2011 wherever.
That in our data economy
and Information Society,
there are really
three emerging groups of
people: the data creators;
those who consciously or
unconsciously could
produce all the data,
unconsciously like in
social media I guess.
Those who have the expertise
to analyze the data,
and those who have the means
to access and collect data.
And I realized that
as a researcher,
I was interested in
all these topics
and you will see it's
how issues of epistemology,
data production, but also
a lot data governance
come up in my research across
all different projects.
So I was never really able
to focus just on one side,
so it's stuff that
I'm interested into.
Yeah, I guess I should
also point out that
today I'm mainly
a qualitative researcher even
though I have some training
in programming and
statistics and other types
of research methods,
but I'm mainly an ethnographer.
Well, we'll say
something more about it.
So influence is a method.
I have a PhD into
disciplinary background,
so I studied
communication and then
have this Master
in media studies,
but during my period
as a PhD student,
I think there are
three main areas that really
impacted me as a researcher.
Of course Information Science
and classification theory,
maybe some of you can recognize
the cover of the book from
'Bulkier and Star' and
my own adviser was still
big influence me a lot to
Christine Borgman
who does a lot of
studies in scientific
collaborations,
but also social studies of
data and algorithms especially
critical data studies
that is probably also
feel that some of you
are familiar with.
The other thing is
that basically,
I like to say that I have a
minor in history of science.
History of science really,
a minor as a PhD student
even though it
doesn't exist but, yeah.
So history of science for me
was really really important.
It fuel my work so much.
At UCLA we have
a pretty strong department
of history of science,
people like Thad Potter,
amazing people working there.
And because my work is about how
scientists use biology databases,
for me it was impossible to
make sense of these phenomenon
without looking at how
it evolved through time.
It was like nearly impossible,
even though it was
not required to
take more a historical approach,
but this was really
important for me.
And the second thing
is that somehow it
happened that a lot of my work is
related to issues of race,
which was not something that want
to necessarily write about but
then it just keep
coming up everywhere.
I also specialize in
the history of human variation,
and I'm particularly
interested in
how the biomedical field,
think about the issues of race
and issues of
biological determinism,
I think and then everything
will make sense.
Eventually, hopefully you will
see that I have
all these interests.
Okay, so let me have some water.
Am I talking too fast?
I know that I have an accent,
and I tend to do it.
Anyway, okay, so in
just a short overview of
my collaborative projects,
I like to say that when I joined
my department for
the first time in my life,
I felt that my brain was at home.
I had this feeling
that I went there
and I was surrounded by
all these amazing people.
They could just get what
I was interested into,
and especially my PhD cohort
was an amazing cohort.
We were five or six of us and
we're all interested in
the same things and writing
about data and social issues
and so we collaborate a lot,
it was very natural,
and it was not required
at all but it was
a very fruitful type of
a collaborative environment.
So the first event that we
organized just after a few months
we started the project
was this hackathon event,
it was in early 2015.
In this specific event,
we invited community members
from the LA area to
come to this event and
together we downloaded
and analyzed
different publicly
available datasets
on police officer homicides.
Police officer
involved homicides.
So our main question was to
understand the what type of
informations were out there
and how accurate
these information were.
We divided our collaboration
in a few groups.
I was reading
the data mining to group.
We did some simple,
not maybe that simple,
it depends on your
skills I guess,
querying of different
datasets because we had,
for example, one dataset
from the FBI,
that was released from FBI,
one dataset collected
by journalists,
one dataset collected by
community members and I was
very interested in seeing for
a specific time and place
how these datasets were
reporting the occurrence of,
let me say, differently,
and I found
some interesting stuff that I
don't have to talk about now,
but you can ask questions,
or I can talk about this later,
or with you individually.
Now, we organized another event,
and this was last year
during Inauguration Day.
You probably heard about similar
events around the country.
This was done in connection
in collaboration with
Data Refuge and EDGI.
So during this day,
we invited- this was
an archival tone,
how you call it,
archival tool and
use that information sciencey
type of intervention.
In this case, we had to
nominate some
datasets that were at
risk of being deleted
during government transition
because you probably,
as you know, when you
change government in
the United States,
new governments,
they all tend to
delete content from
public- from government websites
and to replace it
with new content.
So we were very much
interested in rescuing,
in saving both content and
data related to climate change.
And then I ended up
writing this paper with
a colleague of mine,
with Christine,
who was also PhD student,
because I wanted to
know again this is
my interest in data governments
that always comes up.
I wanted to know how this is
possible in the first place.
Why there are
no policies that they
protect these government websites
from being completely deleted.
Do we have anything
in place that kind
of archives the type of website
somewhere beyond
the internet archive?
Again, so we wrote this
paper together which we will
present next month or two months.
Okay, but my main
secondary project that
this was a continuous
collaboration.
It's actually this project
which was done in
collaboration with
the Institute for Society
and Genetics at UCLA and
this part lab which is run by
Chris Kelty with
Anthropology of Science
and Scientific Collaborations.
I've joined this group
probably my third
year, my second year,
so it's been a couple
of years that
we analyze and observed how
white nationalists understand and
interpret results from
genetic ancestry testing.
Okay. Particularly I was,
particularly interested in seeing
how these white nationalists,
once they receive
results, they are mixed.
So they're not 100 percent white.
How they reacted to these results
and how they tried
to make sense of it.
And because my main dissertation
project is on open data,
I was interested
in seeing and how
data circulates in between
different platforms,
because one thing that they do,
which again you can ask
me questions later,
is, so they download
the raw data from
the companies' websites.
Right because there are
these companies like 23andMe,
that they run ancestry testing
for you and then you can
download your raw data
and you can upload
the raw data on
third-party calculators and they
recalculate the data
and they give
you basically a different result,
because it's also based on
the kind of reference
populations that they
have their own samples and so on.
And apparently, it turns out
that these alternative
calculators,
they retrieve whiter results
for some reason,
that it's really difficult
to download because
they are black-boxed.
Anyway, so this was
my secondary project.
Okay, so this was kind of
an overview of
my collaborative projects.
But, the main lab
I've been working
on is the Center for
Knowledge Infrastructures.
I joined the Center right after I
started my PhD program
and so from day
one I was a research
assistant with this lab and I
started collecting data at
my research community
really early.
And I joined this grant that
basically funded
my whole PhD life.
Well, not this year, but
my first three years.
The grant is called,
If Data Sharing is the Answer,
What is the Question?
And it broadly investigates
this current trend in
science policy that maybe
you're familiar with, maybe not,
which is to make
available to the public,
to the whole
international community,
and also to the industry,
as much as possible,
research data.
Okay. In our lab,
we are like six researchers.
Each of us, we focus on
a different discipline.
So, I have a colleague who is
working on astronomy data,
a colleague who is working
on Earth science, and so on.
So the idea is that eventually,
at the end of the project
to come together and make
comparisons between
how these issues
are different in
different domains.
So, my specialization
is genomic medicine,
and I will tell you more
about my specific case study.
But before presenting
my research questions
I thought that I should
give you some background,
because this is
a less intuitive program
compared to other
things I wrote about.
You really have to
know what is going on.
Okay. So, first of all,
I am writing and I'm talking
about research data.
So these are not
clinical trial data.
These are research data that are
collected to answer specific
research questions.
And I'm saying this
because I was at Hicks
last week and someone asked me,
"What's the difference
between research data
and social media data?"
There is no difference. I don't
understand why you
want to focus on
research data as opposed
to social media data.
I was like, 'I think I'm very
interested in research data
because research data are
used for scientific
knowledge production,
which is a specific type of
knowledge production that comes
with specific expectations.'
Right? So scientific
knowledge production is,
first of all, cumulative.
Right? We stand on
the shoulders of the giants.
So it builds upon itself and then
it's peer reviewed and it's
validated in a collaborative way.
Right? So this is
the main reason.
Now, one of the main
differences between
research data and
other types of data,
then, it's publicly funded,
so at least the type of
data that I look at,
that's another characteristic
of publicly funded,
so it's an investment.
So it's a resource and
basically also a commodity.
And then I read this difference
in a paper and I found,
I thought it was interesting.
While we can see that social
media data are found data,
research data are crafted data.
So this difference between
crafted and found.
Crafted because, again,
research data are
collected to ask
a specific hypothesis,
also large scale datasets,
at least in my community,
and with the researchers
that I work with,
not maybe all research data,
but I believe there is
always a hypothesis in mind.
And, so, what I was saying?
And then within a specific
experimental setting,
and to ask specific
research questions.
Okay. The second thing
that I want to
introduce to you is the
open data movement in science,
which is different from
the open data movement
in government.
For example, biology and
biomedicine has a long history
of data sharing and reuse.
So biology has been
doing this for
a long time, and then, again,
I read a lot of books about it,
but which help me to really to
characterize the new
open data movement.
So how is it now different?
Two main reasons: first of all,
now making data
publicly available is
becoming a requirement
by funding agencies.
So if you want to
collect new datasets,
you have to- again,
you will see that this is
specifically what is going
on in my case study,
but if you want to
collect the data,
you have to basically
demonstrate that you will make
the data publicly available.
While, before, traditionally,
the way a biologist shared
the data is like this,
'Okay, I am a biologist,
I collect the dataset and then
I mine and analyze my dataset,
I publish a publication,
then along with the publication
I release my raw data or
some summary-level data along
with my publication
and then a biocurator,
who is this figure in
biology and databases,
comes in and harvests the data
from the papers and from
the open repositories and
then makes available the
data to the public.'
So usually, traditionally,
data are released
after publication in
the traditional open movement.
And it's also very much
community-driven. Please
ask your question.
>> Just for clarification,
is the biocurator a human
being or is it a machine?
>> So, for now,
it's a human being.
We will see. But
now it's actually,
I believe it has to
be. You never know.
But a biocurator is simply
a very important role,
because they usually
are people that know
biology ontology really well.
So they have this
idea of how knowledge
is represented and organized.
So they harvest
the summary-level data
from publications and
then they curate it at
the metadata and onto
logical terms and
relationships and then they
upload it on bioinformatics
tools. Please.
>> I'm just trying to say if they
attached to a specific journal
or if [inaudible].
>> Yes.
so in my experience, and I think,
probably most of
the cases, biocurators,
they work for different
platforms so databases,
they have their own biocurators.
So, maintain the platform
and also harvest
data from different
publications and journals.
So, it used to be more
community-driven,
open data in genomic medicine.
Now it's more like, it's
increasingly required,
still a lot of scientists
that do not to share their data,
but what I'm talking
about are the new grants
have been accepted. Please.
>> If new grants are approved,
who is requiring this?
>> Right. Funding bodies.
Funding bodies like
funding agency.
>> NIH or like?
>> Yeah, yeah. Basically, NIH.
Because I've worked
with biomedical data,
so my case study is NIH-funded,
a group of collaboration.
Yes. But I know that also
some private foundations are
increasing requiring it,
but they mainly work with
publicly funded data
collections. So, yeah.
>> Is this only on genomics
or there's another?
>> Let me think.
I think it's that
biomedicine is like 90 percent
genomic right now, I think.
So, yeah.
I would say there is
a specifically genomic
data for sure.
We'll see some few
more about it but-
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes, yes. All data
needs to be identified.
My work is not that much
about privacy than
identifications,
but there is a lot
of work in that.
They're showing that, yes,
it identified, but
to some extent,
you can't read and
de-identify a DNA or someone,
so there is a lot of
research in that direction.
But for sure, these data
are shared with
specific de-identification
techniques even though,
as you will see, my community
collects face images
from children,
so that's impossible to
de-identify, obviously.
I mean, if that's
how do you do it.
So, but yes, there are
a lot of requirement,
they're very careful
with privacy.
Okay. So now the idea is
that data are
required to be sure,
but also there is
this portion making
the data available right
after data collection
before publication,
before the scientist, before
the data creator herself
can mind and make
sense of the data.
The idea is that when the data
comes back up from
the sequencing facility,
you have to make it available,
or usually, give you six months,
which is really not that much to
analyze a larger scale data
set of genomic data.
So why all this interest in
making this data available,
requiring to make data available
right after data collection?
So, I read a lot of
documents and grants
under different reasons
why different people wants
to push for these
open data movement.
But I think from the funding
bodies point of view,
there is this idea of
a fast efficient science.
We want to make research,
especially public research,
as fast and as
efficient as possible.
So if you have one
large scale data set,
and then the person collected it,
and the only person
who is minding it
to ask my own research question,
they're not subtlety efficient.
In an ideal situation,
you want to have
10 other researchers
who at the same time,
while I am analyzing
my own data set,
they come in and they ask
different research questions,
each of them, right?
They're different also from mine
or from the same data set,
and this is the big promise
of open data in biomedicine.
The idea that you can do that
in a way that can be like,
so the research process
is very efficient and you
have a high return on
investment, right?
So, I believe that from
the funder's point of view,
is mainly a return
of investment idea.
But in order to do that,
you have to make data fungible,
which is not my expression.
Actually, Sabina Leonelli,
in her brand new book,
Data-Driven Biology,
she talks about
this move of making
biology data fungible data.
And if you know
someone from Econ,
by you probably recognized
that these are economics term,
which basically means that you
have to have these data turn
into some commodities that
are interchangeable and that
they speak for themselves.
So you have to make this in
a way that anyone can come,
and trust this data and
mind this data even though
this researcher did not
witness the collection of
the data in the first place.
So how do you do it?
You either try to make
them context-free,
or as Sabina Leonelli seen,
you have to pack it,
the data set, in a way
that can travel and
can go into this journey
between different
research situations.
So this is idea of data packages.
Okay, I think I've
said enough about it.
Okay. So these are my main three
research questions, basically.
When I was reviewing
all these literature,
and I got very much
interested into figuring
out on what was going on with
all these open data movement,
I realized that I couldn't
find that via paper,
there was one paper,
there was describing how
people were using these data.
So it's all about, right now,
it's a lot about the promise of
open data and how do we make
these data to speak for
themselves in other things,
but they couldn't find
a description of typology or
characterization of
the actual practices
of reusing this data.
So, I went to
my field and I started asking
people and observing them,
'How are you actually using
open data that you did
not collect yourself,
for your own research?'
That's kind of my main research
question, the first one.
And then, I wanted to
see because it's specific
in this community,
it's a new phenomenon to make
all these data available,
I wanted to see all
of these policies and
these transition
from requirement,
pre-publication data sharing,
is changing the way
researchers do
their research practices.
And then I figure out that
these data were reused
a lot outside academia and
outside the medical field.
And I found it fascinating,
these data were collected to
ask biomedical questions,
and then they were
re-used in topic,
in context that didn't have
anything to do with biomedicine.
So I did this chapter
to my dissertation,
which we don't have
much time to talk about.
I wanted to tell you
everything about everything,
but that's not doable.
So I'm going to give you
an overview of what is
my thought right now
about the first two
research questions mainly.
Okay, let me introduce
you to my community,
to these NIH-funded consortium.
There are around
15 labs involved.
They are geographically
distributed
around the United States,
and also, they have
some collaboration
in other states lab.
I visited six of these labs,
so the goal of these researchers
and their funding,
to collect them and make
completely publicly available,
of course with some privacy,
so they have to have
IRB if you want to use
the data for research.
So make completely
available prior to
publication right
after data collection,
so the data comes back from
the sequencing facility,
you do some quality control,
and then you have to
make it available.
And they call these data
collections themselves
hypothesis-free genomic data
which I, yeah.
I don't think it's
really hypothesis-free
and then we're talking redundant,
they actually are aware of it.
These high throughput data
because it's collecting
with next sequencing
technologies and so on.
Some data types, I'm not
going to explain you
today the difference
between these data types,
about whole genome sequencing,
expression data from ChIP-seq
and RNA-Seq experiments,
if you are familiar with it,
microarrays, all of microarrays
but especially, the most we use
the data types are
genotypes and phenotypes
from GWAS studies,
Genome-Wide Association
Studies and
I will tell you something
more about this specific one.
It is a community that
is very interesting
for me because it's
very interdisciplinary.
So, I took with
computational biologists,
the wet lab biologists,
developmental biologist,
human geneticists,
surgeons and I think
that's also why to some extent
I think at my findings can
be generalized to conduct
their research biomedical
research environment today
because you have all these
different disciplinary
configurations.
Okay. So GWAS studies.
So, the main idea
of GWAS study is to
collect large scale
datasets of genotypes,
so genes data, sequence data,
and phenotypes.
So, like images,
mainly in this case,
images of the face.
So, how these data
were collected?
DNA samples and images
from the face were
collected from over 3,000
Caucasian children
and then the DNA
was genotype for specific needs
for specific genetic mutations
that they were known to
be connected to fish or
the morphology and then
the face images were studied
to extract the metrics.
So, landmarks and metrics
that can be used to quantify
the face and then of
course everything was made
available and the idea
was for everybody to come and
mine the data to find
a correlation between
the mutation in the genome
and specific official features.
The thing about this dataset,
is that the database
which is called the 3D
Facial Norms Database,
is that it was highly
reusing connection in
a network way in connection with
other databases in the way
that they have
different populations.
Like population from Tanzania
was used, population from,
so different type of
ethnicities or as
they say populations were
using connection
with this dataset.
So, the important thing
to understand
is that the researchers
who collected
these data and they do
research in the biomedical area
like all of them,
literally all of them.
None of them collected
these data to
do anything else than
conducting research in what is
called the Craniofacial Research.
So, they deal with
rare syndromes that
are expressed at
birth in the face.
I didn't want to capitalize
by using an image
of a child with
a Craniofacial birth defect.
Okay. So, I show you this poster
from this movie because it
tells the story of one of
these children with one
of these syndromes.
So, this is the context in which
the data are collected and
what the researchers
write about them.
This is one example of
how you can extract
some metrics from
a facial imagine.
And you can understand
that it's probably
not difficult for you
to imagine how these data
can be reused in
all sorts of ways.
Once you quantify
the piece of body
and is such an important
piece of our body
right is the main way we express
our identities it can be
used in all sorts of ways,
this is just some stupid app
or that wants to give
you your ancestry profile
based on your facial metrics.
>> Is that drawing on this
same data? Or is that different?
>> So, well, it's
difficult to tell,
it's kind of the same idea
but I will show you
an example that is drawn
from the same data.
This is just I founded
and it reminds me a lot.
Also this one I don't know if
it's drawn from the same idea,
but I know that the they
were the first to
really quantify the face and
develop these new really
accurate metrics.
So, I know that
these metrics are used
a lot and I would
assume that probably,
yes, certain landmarks and
metrics there are very accurate.
So, they could be reused
in all sorts of ways.
But probably the most
problematic in my opinion,
the way in which this data
was reused was to develop
the forensic DNA
phenotyping technique,
which I know if you're
familiar with maybe you
heard about this
before by this idea
of collecting some DNA from
a crime scene and then
reconstruct the face
of the suspect.
All digitally and
computationally.
Well, I know that the research
that comes out from
this collaboration in
between it was integrated
with other databases in
a natural way and
all these things.
But informed the development of
some prototypes for
this type of research.
And this is what the last chapter
of my dissertation is about.
So, just to give you
an idea of what is
the value in this data that
I look at in the
scientific practices.
Okay. So, just a few words
about my research methods,
I don't want use too much time
to talk about these,
you can ask me questions later.
I collected over 50 interviews
with these populations,
I spend over 200 days
in between these labs.
Maybe mine is not
a traditional ethnography in
the sense that I
didn't spend time at
one site is more base
of interviews
but I spend from two to
four weeks at each lab though.
So I had the opportunity to
see all the data collection,
how it happened and then
I read and analyze a lot
of documents and things.
Okay. So, just to remind you,
my research questions were about.
So, my main goal is
still possible to understand
how the scientists are
reusing this data.
So, data reused practices.
So first of all, I
immediately noticed
that scientists when
they were talking about,
how do you use the data, and
when I pose these questions,
they were referring
to different things.
So, someone then they would
give me some answer didn't
have anything to do
with some other answers
and it took me a long time
for me to come up with
a typology with
a characterization of
the different practices
because it's not clear,
there is not a language
to talk about it.
So, my first goal
was to give them and
myself a language to talk
about what do you mean,
when you talk about data reuse.
So, one distinction that was
keep coming up was between
what they eventually called
background reuse of data and
foreground reuse of data.
So, background reuse of data,
refers to these traditional way
that I already described to you,
of reusing each other data,
which means that these are data
that are accessed from shared,
first of all, along
with the publication.
They're accessed on
bioinformatics tools
and they are used for
contextualization and
mainly they visualize them.
So, this is kind
of the main idea.
These are two databases
that are used a lot by
the researchers I talk
with and also outside
the Craniofacial community
one is the Omni dataset,
the other one is
the Genome Browser.
You probably heard about it, it's
a very popular tool and the way
scientists reuse
these platforms daily.
So it's a very common
practice they mainly go on
these platforms and then
type the name of the gene,
they want to retrieve all
the information that is known.
So this is known
knowledge and then
they, through
these visualizations,
they access these validated set
of knowledge around
specific biological entities.
They use it to setup
their experiments,
so before conducting
an experiment or to interpret
the statistical findings or
preliminary findings from
experimental practice.
As opposed to foregrounds reuse.
So foreground reuse is where
all the promise about
open data takes place.
It's about running
secondary data analyses
of others the raw data.
Okay. We all know
the raw data is an oxymoron,
but I mean a low process data.
Okay. So, these like
different practice comes with
a set of completely
different deals.
So, while for whenever
the access others' data
for background they
use the access data
that is known and
works as a reference
whenever you go,
you want to mind someone
that's raw data,
it's more about
knowledge rediscovering.
The potential of
the raw dataset is unknown.
So, you don't know what
you're going to find.
Also because remember that
as I was telling you,
all this data was collected
was made available
prior to publication.
So, not even a data creator
knows what she can
find in the data.
So, everything is collected
in the potentially some
known this is kind of
unexplored data and
while data reuse background
are highly trusted by
the community later
used foreground researchers were
expressing a lot of
concerns over the quality
of these data.
Mainly because they didn't have
an historical record
that comes with it,
they didn't have a reputation.
Everything was really
kind of unknown.
So, foreground reuse is
a very emerging practice.
While researchers
access others' data
in an integrated and
visualize way on
bioinformatics tools
everyday whenever was asking,
okay, when was the last time
you actually reused,
reanalyzed someone else raw data,
it was really rare.
So, it's a very emerging practice
even though it officially
constitutes the real promise
of open data movement that.
I think I said everything
I wanted to say about
these more or less. Yes.
Great. If you're doing this
that's fine to tell me.
The foreground case,
there's a lot of work to
go through that raw data,
so I think you are doing
data analysis like
10 years or whatever,
you might get credit for it
one way or another, right?
So instead of A, people to
produce data but then [inaudible]
results from it or B, for
the other people to say,
'You know, that person did.'
They've probably
already done a lot
of processing before they
released it and I'm really behind
so why would I work on it.
Does that come up in
your conversations?
>> Well, yeah, this is
also the question that I
was wondering. All right.
Yes. So the main
incentive I think,
especially in this collaboration,
the sharing came as
a package with collection,
so the idea was to collect
this hypothesis-free data.
That problem is that obtaining
a grant from NIH to collect the
hypotheses-free data
is really difficult
because you have to show one,
usually you have to
show that you have
specific research type
of trajectory.
So the idea was like, 'Okay.
We're gonna give you
the funding to collect
these large datasets but,
in return, you have to make
everything available
after publication.'
I think now it's very
idealistic like is
exactly what you are saying.
It's this idea just
because it's a lot,
it means that everybody can come,
we should make it super
efficient, right?
Yeah. It's kind of ideal
practice but then,
as you are saying,
the social incentives,
they're not much there.
But I will say a
little bit more on how
these are actually used.
Because, well, thank
you for that question.
The thing is that, when I
talk with the researchers,
I found that they
could disconnect in
the way they describe
this practice of
running secondary
data analysis in
a hypothetical way and
how they actually do it.
And because this is
social media collective I
created a little meme
for you guys.
Thank you for getting it.
I was a little bit worried.
Are memes still a thing?
I don't even know.
It kind of feels a little
bit dated but anyway.
Okay. So the ideal practice in
which people describe running
secondary analyses.
They are like, Yeah.
So I go in someone
else's database,
I download their raw data,
and then I reanalyze
data to ask my own
research questions.'
And I'm like, 'Okay. When was
the last time you did it?'
They're like, Well,
I don't actually do
it but someone else does it.
Okay. Can I talk to someone
else who is doing it.
And it wasn't happening
that much but I knew
that they were
reanalyzing others' data.
So it's like, 'Can
you please tell me
exactly how you do it?'
And it turns out that this
specific community, at least,
really values
the collaboration with
the data creator when
they reanalyze
someone else's raw data.
So what they do is they
literally call up the person who
created the data and we
disperse they negotiator.
The way that it is
accessed and reused.
The community really value
this collaboration
with the data creators
and data re-users.
And in my dissertation chapter,
I then ask a lot of questions
once I realize this,
which took a while of how
exactly and why exactly
this collaboration is so
important and is for
many reasons that I don't have
time to describe all of them
but just kind of foster.
So, it allows for skills and
knowledge integrations
because most of
the datasets are collected
by qualitative sorry,
by wet lab biologists
that they have
a great understanding of
the biological functions
behind the data collection but
mostly computational biologists
run secondary data analysis,
so by collaborating with each
other they can
integrate their skills.
It's just a matter
of version control
because when you
deposit the dataset,
you deposit this dataset with
all the known knowledge,
annotation data,
metadata that you know about
the dataset at the time
in which you deposit it.
But as Phil Agre was saying,
datasets are living things.
So more the data creator
works with a dataset,
the more she understands
things about it.
So if you can contacted
the data creator directly,
you have the most
up-to-date version of
the dataset and know
the information and
variables that goes with it.
It also helps for faster
access to protected data.
We were seen there were
these issues of privacy,
and if you join someone as IRB,
you've probably even
heard about this
before, it's much easier,
especially if you're
asking similar questions
and obtaining your IRB.
So that's another reason why,
especially to download
data from some platforms,
it's faster to do this.
And it also kind of
encourages to develop
trust in this high throughput
data, unexplored data,
because the reputation of
the data creator kind of works as
a substitute for the lack
of reputation of
the dataset itself.
And by then, and maybe
most importantly,
it helps scientists to
deal with the issues
of credit attribution.
Because most of
these secondary analyses,
they end up in co-authorship.
So what happens is
that you receive,
both the data creator
and the data collector,
receive a credit together
for the secondary data analysis.
Another thing that I didn't have
much time to talk about but it's
a big issue of great attribution
invisible labor,
because it is easy when
you hear PI's saying,
this is a little provocation,
saying, "Oh yes.
All data should be
made openly available right now."
Too bad that the people who
collected data are
usually post-docs,
and if you try to be
a post-doc in biology
today it's really hard.
The post-docs I talk with
were post-docs for seven,
eight years and it
was really hard
and all they have are
their data, like nothing else.
So, for the PI's of
course, 'Yeah, yeah.
Let's make everything available.'
For the post-doc it's like,
that's not exactly that easy.
And there are other issues of
invisible labor but we
can talk about this data.
So where all this leaves us?
So I thought a lot
about all these kinds of
tensions that are going on in
this open data
movement and I think
that what I'm witnessing is
the competitions of
two different views
of what science should look like.
So on one side,
you have this idea of data that
have to speak for themselves,
and there is all these pushes,
especially in
the informatics community,
to curate the data in
a way that you create
a separation between the
data creator and data user.
So it's actually
seen as a bad thing.
Like the fact that
you have to call
someone up to reuse their data,
absolutely a bad thing.
It's like stigmatized.
Yeah, you shouldn't
be able to do that.
I'm like, 'Why you shouldn't
be able to do this?'
Anyway. And then there is this
some funders said they have
this fund, this strategy,
that is centered on
the collecting new data and
make everything available,
which leads to all these issues
of competition and rush to
data reuse and then also
these problems of
invisible labor and workforce.
The other side, you
have people they
understand science,
the data science,
more as a collaborative practice,
where knowledge validation and
not just knowledge productions
is understood as something
that we do it together.
I really like this idea of,
which probably someone
else wrote about already,
of objectivity as
a collaborative practice.
I really like to
think about this.
And then where data creators,
they contribute to
the secondary analyses
of their own data
where the funding is about
bringing people together,
not just of how
bringing data together.
And also where data
creators and data users,
they receive credit for
their work so they end
up in co-authorship.
So with our lab,
the Center for
Knowledge Infrastructures,
they thought a lot about
interventions because, okay,
we write about
all these nice things,
but then we work with the
scientists and we want to help.
So we like to think
about ourselves as
some sort of mediators between
the different visions
of science and
that's why we organize
the opportunity to
bring together people,
we organize some
workshops, surveys,
we did it the users,
and in my specific community,
I would like to organize
a Hackathon event.
And my idea for
a Hackathon event in
this case is where you have
the data creators that they
present their own datasets
and you deal with
issues of credit attribution and
also how these datasets again
really used and I
really think that could
be really valuable to have
the people who collected
the data in the event itself.
Okay. So, out of
all this monstrous dissertation,
I have three main papers
that I want to write.
One is called, you
shall like my title,
How I Met Your Data.
Thank you for getting these all.
So the role of data creator and
re-user collaboration in
reusing open data than.
The science policy paper,
which is the making
a fungible open data winners and
losers in a fast science.
And then I have a STS
the more kind of-
>> The post-docs and so forth?
What are the winners
and the losers?
>> Yes, exactly. Like
what kind of competing views.
Yes. Not just about
the post-docs but I guess from
a disciplinary
configuration because
I think that increasingly,
people who have
a great understanding of
the biology but maybe a lack of
computational skills
will be set back
by this model of science.
And then a STS journal paper,
which is mostly about
my third chapter.
I didn't have time
to talk about today,
which is the idea of how do you
create and collected data in
a biomedical context and then
reuse them to something
completely different.
And this type of work is
especially related to
issues of race because,
at least so far,
my understanding is that
it really didn't
have any meaningful-
There was not really
a reason of having
different ethnicities to
investigate these syndromes.
So while race becomes
important when you want to use
it outside the biomedical field
or to develop these technologies.
So at what point race becomes
important basically,
as a concept?
And then, because
I read a lot about
the history of
Craniofacial medicine,
but also on the
quantification of the face.
And this is the history
that is related
with the history of
human variation and
biological determinism and race,
identification of the body,
and all these things,
I have these idea which
right now of course
it's up in the air because
I'm writing my dissertation,
I'm writing a book that
potentially could be
called Data Face'',
how the human face became
a quantifiable commodity.
So, like, tell
all the stories about
all these different
perspectives on the face.
They came to be
together and how they
intersect to eventually have
a quantifiable commodity,
that is our face.
Yeah, I made it.
>> Why it doesn't seem
people have questions?
>> Did you mention about
the techniques that you
really going to talk about?
The data again used [inaudible]
>> So, the main use that I'm
investigative is
these, what is it?
These forensic DNA
phenotyping techniques.
But these data were used
in all sorts of ways.
The other thing was
used it is used
to develop technologies and
tools devices related
to the face like
head phones design
and glasses design.
But another very interesting
application is for
the automation of diagnoses,
for rare syndromes
so that someone
else actually in
Israel they developed
this app that doctors
they can use in
remote places where they don't
have access to the literature.
And they can with this app take
a picture of the child that
potentially has the Craniofacial
abnormalities syndrome.
Then the app retrieves a list of
potential syndromes related to
these specific phenotype
but there was
another very interesting
application of this data.
But the one that
fascinated me the
most was probably
these DNA phenotyping.
So, yes, in this case,
the knowledge behind
the development of
these technologies was developed
by a lab that collaborated
with the labs indeed,
as we'll see with
the data creators themselves.
So, the people who collected
the data were not really
interested in actually issues of
race and because
the whole point of
DNA phenotyping is dividing
people by race, right?
Because that's the whole point.
Because that's what they
want to do, to say,
'Okay, you are from
this that population.'
It's mainly, also because
it doesn't give you
so many details that you can
actually identify one person.
This is like a generic
representation.
So what was I saying?
Right. So the data creators
they were not conducting
this research at
all but they collaborated with
different labs that developed
this type of knowledge.
That then was used and then
informed the design of
these technologies,
so there are some startups
in New York who are
doing these and
their main clients are police
stations, police officers.
I saw some of them at some talks.
Actually, one of
the data creators,
one of the labs that
collected these type of data,
one of the postdocs,
she gave this talk,
where she basic explained
that you can't do these.
That makes no much sense from
a scientific point of view
and she was in her study,
she basically did not find
a correlation between
certain metrics and
ethnicity groups.
Then there were some
police officers in
the room and they were asked
asking question about it.
So, how should we trust
the technology or not?
So it is used right now
and I read a couple of
articles that it was used in
some child but it's
still very emerging.
It is not validated like
DNA things and even
though so DNA actually comes
from your sort of problems.
There is one author, she's
in Europe in Amsterdam,
Amanda Charik that she's writing
about the specific
issues and yes,
my work is very much
informed by her work.
She is anthropologist.
>> On that note DNA creator,
DNA re-user relationship that you
found difference with
their different institutions,
like imagine they pick up
the phone and have
a conversations with like
two biologists that were
from other universities and
on opposite coasts
but what about when
it's the data creators
of biologists
in the research university
have a re-user is a cop,
a social media company
or something like that.
What is the relation?
>> Okay, good question.
One think I think about, it
depends, let's first talk
about in a university context.
In the academia,
the main challenge is
between people who conducts
research on animal models and
people who conducted
research on humans
because they have to translate
each other knowledge but also
because they have
different types of
access so if you will conduct,
if your lab mainly
does research with
mice and zebrafish or
whatever all animal models.
So you can't really
have access to
human unprotected data.
So they want to collaborate
but then they have to
deal with your sort of
institutional requirements.
So, I think that's mainly it
but if you are a researcher,
I think usually it is not that
difficult to collaborate.
I don't think about any other
institutional challenge.
So the final thing is, that
with human unprotected data,
you probably heard
about this before,
if you want to
reuse research data
for an academic publication
you have to have the IRB.
Right? The IRB for academic work.
If you want to reuse it for
commercial purposes you have
to guarantee that you're
using anonymized way.
You have some requirements but
you don't even need an IRB
actually because IRB's just
for academic publications.
So the weight worked
based on my observations
in the specific study,
is that again you have one
research lab collecting data.
Then you have
all these mediators labs
that were not really
involved there but they're
still in a research university,
will reuse these data to
develop some knowledge.
Then these researchers,
I think their work
as consultants for
private companies. So you have-
>> Now, they have data model.
>> Yes, that's why, exactly.
Follow the data you will
see what's going on.
So, that's how it
moves on, and then,
the other important thing
to remember is
that you've always use
their network way,
because you if have
one dataset with
just Caucasian people,
it's not really useful.
So, then it's highly
integrated with
datasets from Europe.
All right, the other thing
that's another thing
that they do,
right is they send
postdocs around.
So, there was this postdoc
who participating the collection
of data on a different
population in
Europe and then she's
now working lab,
but they are
collecting these data.
So, then they can integrate
each other data and other things.
Then some other datasets
are in Saudi Arabia,
so it's a kind of an actual type
of a way, but yes,
one thing that I want to
do with lectures exactly,
how these data moves around,
there was like integrated in
between different resources.
So, there's not one
way of doing it,
I feel like all these little
steps that you do when,
people they don't just
comes collaborative
like a natural way.
It's not like they have
a master plan or something.
>> I have a question about
the population. [inaudible]
>> Yeah
>> In a positive way,
or a secondary data,
is there a standardized
vocabulary for
how population sets
are talked about or
does everybody have their own
concept of race and does it
get somehow modeled in
a process, how are they?
Is there an emergent taxonomy?
Is there a practice taxonomy
or is it just still kind of?
>> This is very
interesting and it's one
that I want to look into.
I'm not at that point
yet, but it's definitely.
I know that in
biomedicine you have
certain ways to
define populations.
Right? They are called
population and then solve
the same biomedical research
usually you don't
use it like race.
You don't call it race at all.
You call it populations.
And I would say, yeah,
they use the name of
the place where it
was collecting,
like the New Jersey population
which is real population.
Amsterdam population,
the Tanzania population,
but it would be interesting
to see if there are
some variation language for sure.
It's definitely one
thing I will look into.
Yes, and there's
a few changes when you're
using a different context
and body. Yeah.
>> When they're
using India dataset
and then in the United States.
Police department will use that.
>> I see, okay.
Yes, so one passage that maybe I
wasn't 100 percent
clear about is that
there is a difference between
the research data that
are used to develop
the technologies to
the knowledge and forms of
technologies and
the reference datasets
used by police officers.
So, the research data is
all the data that I looked into,
but then police officers
they uses data in
connection with their own
reference databases
so they don't use,
they don't use their
research data directly.
I really hope they're
not doing this.
It will be kind of crazy if they,
also because
the researcher datasets
are about children images.
So, those informed knowledge
that then is used to develop
the technologies but
then the references
datasets are datasets
collected from all of us IDs and
driver license they are like
datasets from population and
another thing that
I read about is
this problem that then
they develop this profile,
this feature profile
and then is run
against datasets
of police officer,
datasets are ready biased in
themselves so you have
all these issues of
bias that keep like building
up. Does that makes sense?
>> Coming to dataset,
in the studies,
once they are published, is there
any trace of the background
of which dataset?
Are they sited in
any way or it just
formal like the questions
that comes [inaudible].
>> It is sited because at least,
for the dataset they look at,
they say that's actually how I
found out about these, right?
I actually found
out because someone
came when I started
doing this research.
Someone from the community,
and I think this is interesting,
came to me and told me,
"Well, but do you know how
these data are reused?
You should write about these
because I think this
is problematic."
Then, the other
information that I had,
some journalistic I was like,
'Ah, what's going on?'
Exactly. I was really
happy when this happens as
an ethnographer and then
so what I did, I
didn't start on that.
I went to look
all the publications
and they look for
all the publication that
site this consortium and
then that's how I find out.
>> The question I thought was,
can you tell when you use
FaceBase's data
where the data came
from and where the
FaceBase's data
or are they producing
the data themselves?
>> Yes. No, they're
producing it to themselves.
So the consortium is both about
the collection of the data
and make them available.
So, if you use
the definite FaceBase Consortium
you have the list of people
there who collected
the data who are
these Craniofacial
researchers doing
research on rare syndromes,
so that kind of make sense?
>> This is kind of like the
display teaching practice because
if all you're doing with
the background data is point
of visualization towards to
a hypothesis or a thought like
It wouldn't necessarily site
that from my knowledge.
>> Right. Yes, that's
a great question.
So another thing that
maybe got lost in
these process is that,
actually these data did
the FaceBase consortium
mainly the idea
is to make data available at
raw level or a low-process level.
So, they do not have
many visualizations tools.
So, mostly the idea is to reuse
data for foreground in
this specific community.
So, but the fact is that,
that was also for me
confusing at the beginning
because I was asking them,
"So how do you use other's data?"
And they were describing
to me background reuse,
but they were supposed
to do foreground reuses,
so that's why I needed
the language to distinguish
this practice
because I was asking
something they were
answering something else.
It was so confusing
at the beginning.
So, yes, thank you
but I know this is
kind of all the rewind
of somehow.
>> Let's call time.
>> Thank you for
coming everybody.